hi this is presh talwiker let's discuss  an infinite exponential  let's say you need to solve for x in the  equation x to the power of x to the  power of x to the power of x infinitely  repeated is equal to two  how do you solve it if you want to take  a stab pause the video otherwise keep  watching for the solution  the trick is to observe a pattern the  exponent is x to the power of x to the  power of x and so on and we know this is  equal to two  therefore we can rewrite the problem as  x squared is equal to two  which then means x is equal to the  square root of two  i hope you like this video please  subscribe to my channel i make videos on  math and game theory you can support me  on patreon catch me on my blog mind your  decisions  on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can  get my books